welcome with a big apology for being
late my name is sebastian 'the one of
audacity it's my great pleasure to open
a new series of audacity talks they
invite innovators inventors from Silicon
Valley accomplished people to talk to us
into our students worldwide today it's
my great honor to have with me my good
friend Tony Fadell CEO and founder of
nest the inventor of the iPod and many
other wonderful things to come and join
us in us and mostly answer your
questions as I get them online from you
in this session before I do this I want
to ask him a few personal questions and
see what what inside you can share with
us
I want to go Tony it's great to have you
here thank you sir
it's awesome to be here and it's awesome
be the first first guest ever you're the
first guest ever I like it and hopefully
I get his office technical problems in
later iterations of this show we'll see
yeah I'm sure you will I want to go back
to the very beginnings to 1987 when you
enrolled as an engineering students how
come you wouldn't want to be an engineer
well I wanted to be an engineer all the
way from I think about fourth grade
so for me my education my technical
education started with my grandfather
when I was three years old he was a
superintendent of schools he was an
educator a principal and he trained me
in how to work with my hands to create
things with woods and metals and glass
and all kinds of things we would repair
lawnmowers and bicycles and build
soapbox derby racer Xand and birdhouses
and things so I got into building things
and then in 1979 this crazy I started
learning about this crazy thing called a
computer I was only 10 years old at the
time and I said I want one of those and
my grandfather said that's a tool just
like a hammer just like a wrench and I
said I really want that he never touched
a computer his life but he said that's a
tool it's the future and he helped me
buy that first computer you lived in
Detroit at that time is that correct
yeah I lived in Detroit but a car so
being made where cars are being made and
no cost of being taking over a Silicon
Valley eventually buy you but test them
any other idea well you started so what
what what did
engineering education look like 30 years
ago well education for me was you know
the traditional the traditional
education was you went to school you you
know you there's 30 people in a class
and you just got you know told like okay
here's differential equations or here's
computer science or what-have-you but
there was no learning by doing there
were no projects really it was you read
the book you took the test and that's
how it went today
you know there's and there was no
resources besides the library today we
have you know we have Google and the
vast Internet we have things you know
courses like Udacity we have online
collaboration so it's so dramatically
different and it's so crazy that the
things my sons are learning today I
didn't learn until I was you know in my
20s or my teens it's crazy it's
wonderful so for youî the biggest
education was they show your grandfather
that's where it all started even there
was not accredited I guess I'm having
credit and tell me how did he make the
shift from the education college into
your career well all the way from the
first days in high school I started
companies so I knew that I wanted to be
an engineer because I was starting
companies that were engineering based
and I needed a more formal training so I
learned by doing and so for me the way I
knew I wanted to go to school was
because I was doing things and then I
was hitting walls because I didn't know
all the things I needed to know and so I
think that's the right way to be
educated today is you want to do
something you go off and do it and then
you learn the things you need to know to
do it at a high proficiency level makes
me really wonder what was your first
company well my first business excuse me
my first business was selling agro
selling eggs to my neighbors but my
first my first real company was an
educational software company and
mail-order company where you were
programming software and and selling
Apple to hardware and how old were you
when you did this so I was in 11th grade
so I was uh you know about 16 or 17
so it's child labor so to speak I was
the boss though that's true it's true
and you grew with this business did he
have ever employees working for you in
this because yes we had a
so we there was two of us who did the
business and then we had we probably put
on four or five people and then
ultimately I went to college and they
still continued running the business and
they had like 40 or 50 people and then
it ultimately sold I'm so glad you went
to college and they done invented the
iPod we'd head to the iPad and and
eventually through the iPhone which is
great well it takes a team but yeah it
was wonderful times absolutely wonderful
sometime we life you also work in this
building in this very building yes in
1991 I had my very first job in this
very building just one floor down
working with the Mac team the team that
created the Mac without Steve Jobs at
general magic and I was learning from my
heroes I you know you learn in school
how to code but here you at
general-in-chief
learned how to build products and the
process of creating things to take to
market and it was a phenomenal
experience I want to ask you some
questions that our students sent us to
address 'ti ahead of this show and
here's the first one from a student
named Lucas how do I know when to leave
everything behind and follow my dream
it's very broad for sure you have a long
answer to this well I have a long answer
but you know it was that I followed my
dream right here to this building so I
left Michigan
I had a startup company at the time and
I felt in my heart of hearts like I was
this big fish in a small pond so in
Michigan before there were startups and
everything and funding I had heard about
Silicon Valley and I in my gut
everything told me I had been tapped out
my startup company was okay but I wasn't
learning anything and I wanted to go
where there were brilliant people that I
could learn from I wanted to work for my
heroes and so my gut told me run to
Silicon Valley and I begged to get into
general magic and I was Lou you a number
thirty you basically got a greyhound
ticket set in the bus for 30 hours from
from Detroit's to Silicon Valley with
$400 to my name and I came out here and
and I mean did you knock on door so
what'd you do so literally I knocked on
the door general magic at the time at
8:00 in the morning we had I had a tie
on this is silk I didn't know any better
I'd I had my tie on I go in I'm gonna go
ask for a job and literally the people
in the in the offices have been
the whole night there was nobody there
at 8:00 in the morning except these two
people who had been there all night and
they looked at me and said you're gonna
have it can I get hired and they're like
they didn't even know what to say
they're like no we're not hiring come
back you know later kid and I came back
two months later and I kept knocking on
the door knocking on the door and they
finally gave me this wasn't your college
degree or your credentials your
recommendations was your persistence
it was the persistence and the
experience that I had because I actually
had been doing things it was not about
your college degree
it wasn't about where you were from or
your it was the passion and and enough
experience I said this is a young kid he
made it happen he's out here to make to
make his dream happen so when you talk
to this guy gentlemen Lucas who asked
how do you know when to leave everything
behind how do you know that how do you
know for me well there's there's a you
know you have to have your brain you
have the rational part of your brain you
have the emotional part of the brain at
some point you have to you can't there's
no rational way you can assess when you
want to just take a leap and throw
everything behind it has to be purely
emotion so you can gut it's totally gut
now you have to just own that follow
just always your gut you have to listen
to your gut but you have to really make
sure you've learnt let know a little bit
about the risks and make sure you you
know that
you're not going to be out on the street
or what-have-you but enough so that you
go I'm gonna take the leap it's to you
at $4 you're good I had $400 and my mom
and my dad were crying in the driveway
as I was leaving that doesn't even get
you a one-night hotel but we still get
out of these things
yeah and I'm not in Silicon Valley back
then it didn't but no let me ask a
question from Konstantinos another
gentleman on audacity Network again a
very broad question what is the best
piece of advice of curvy advice you've
ever received from a mentor in your life
so I've had a few I've had many mentors
in my life and I've been very you know
lucky to have those mentors but for me
um - two big big things one is you must
always be learning you know in this
field I don't know how many languages
come and go in computer programming
right it was it was Pascal then object
as an objective Pascal and C and C plus
selves here right when I dated dating I
started with Fortran and watt by Fortran
two really basic and pale cord that's
where I start was basic but now it's
Java JavaScript pearl
you know you name it you always have to
continually learn so for like
nanodegrees if you're in your well
employed you should be doing nanodegrees
because you have to constantly learn so
that was the first thing my mentor told
me because this me this this this
technology field moves so rapidly the
second thing is know when to say no now
that must be hard
it's very how did you learn how to say
no well I learned it from Steve Jobs see
Steve said you know we you know people
say ask you know there's so many things
you could be doing and his job was to
say no to so many things and yes to only
those things that really mattered so you
have to really be able to focus your
ever effort your passion your emotion
your energy on those things because you
can only do something so well if you
focus and so that means we say no too
many thing as you move on through life
if may ask this question does it become
harder or easier to say no all right
well for me now it's harder well it's
harder because I have very few
constraints in my life right I have a
great family have just about everything
and now when you have no constraints
it's very hard because the world's your
oyster you can do anything you want when
when you're when when you have only
certain amount of things that's already
narrowed the things you can choose for
it and you still have to say no within
that right but you have to know to win
to say no yeah now and when to say yes
but you're gonna say no much more than
yes and yeah and be consistent I'm a bit
yes we have students from all around the
world from all countries it's quite
amazing
here's two named Bharat he asking you
what helps you Tony to constantly invent
is this the knowledge of things or is
the lack of knowledge is it more
creativity always more consistency well
I think it's two things I think it's a
great question the first one is about
curiosity it's being curious and the
other one is being frustrated so curia
be curious 'ti and frustration so you
want to when you're frustrated then
you're curious as to why
I frustrated and you clue into those
things so you can figure out what's
wrong and then fix it and then your
frustration goes away so it first starts
for me fourth frustration or with
curiosity and those blend together most
people that I know of frustrated just
grumpy grumpy little man you know me
very well I I know you're really well
Tony I want to tell our students what is
the difference between just being
frustrated and what do you do well the
difference is is being frustrated
recognizing that and then taking that
emotion and turning to the positive
light to then go why is it this way so
you can always just run around and
complain about everything right but you
have to take it harness that energy turn
it into positive be curious learn why it
is and sometimes you'll find out the
reason why it is is because of the
constraints of the time and so if you
look a lot of things in the world they
were designed 10 20 30 years ago they
are not a modern design and that's where
you can actually figure out where you
can innovate and create a new business
or a new product or what have you to
make the world a better place because
most times most things were created much
you know back 20 10 20 years ago
Tony I think you just very beautifully
articulated what I think Silicon Valley
is all about what you just said is so
rings true with me and you said it's so
nicely this is really great and this is
exactly what caused you to revolutionize
education question from Rahul would you
advise someone to go out and get some
experience working in the real world
before looking at founding a start-up or
should we just straight jump into
starting a startup company look you have
to learn by doing absolutely you must
learn by doing i I've done both startups
with no experience and I just jumped
into it and I learned by failure so my
whole life you know people see it the
last kind of 15 years of my life has
lots of success but the first 15 years
of my life or 20 years a lot of life was
trying startup after startup and failing
and failing and so I would just go off
and do it because my gut told me to but
then I learned I'm like wait a second I
need to other resources I need to learn
other things and so what I and they and
they say oh you need to work for a big
company you know you work for your own
company or work for a start-up there's
no one path
but you always have to be doing is
learning and trying to adapt even under
pressure when you have failure so for me
the way I think about it is wherever you
start make sure you take an alternate
path so if you start with a big company
then go to a small company see the
differences or if you start your own
startup then go work with a start-up
that's already functioning you're going
to find that you're going to bounce
around a lot and you're going to learn
in all those different environments and
then one day your guts going to tell you
I have enough experience and I have
enough and I have enough passion emotion
my guts telling and you'll strike out
you'll have the right network of people
around you so you can really make a
brilliant startup so there's no one
perfect place to start but you'll know
inside when you've done enough of those
experiences to really make success
advice most most students say try out
things joining the startup for a while
maybe join a bigger company see if you
like it yes and see where you're fit
absolutely find out what works best for
you and make sure you're learning but
let's say you're in a big company make
sure you're not just constrained to that
little box make sure you're talking to
the person next to you talking to
another you know another group doing
another thing make sure you network so
you can learn at a big company a big
company is not just about doing that one
function but it's a you know it's a
smorgasbord of things you can learn from
if you choose to go off and do that and
you have to take advantage of those
resources I mean you go up and in
Detroit and I grew up in Germany and
what you're telling me right now seems
to be exactly the opposite of what I
learned what I learned was Pickers have
a safe spot like go to a big company and
once you have that spot stay there as
long as you can in fact being tended at
a university is exactly this exactly n
so how come you see this so differently
and what can we learn from that well I
think you know sure things are safe you
people want you to be safe you know like
I said my mom was crying going why are
you going this little company I've never
heard of you should be going work for
IBM or something where it's safe because
I want you to be safe
I think the way the world changes is not
by people being safe but by challenging
expectations challenging the
conventional wisdom and if you want to
change the world you need to get out of
the the the the area of safeness you
know it was thought back in you know in
the 40s
40s to the 60s 70s that companies could
take care of you now companies can't
take care of you any longer that was a
myth and we're seeing that everywhere
you have to understand that change is
going to be consonant your life and you
have to adapt to change whether it's in
a big company or small say you work in a
big company today can you this inside a
big company or do you have to break out
and start something else join somebody
else I've started companies with just
myself as an independent I've started
three three divisions of companies
inside of very large companies it can be
done anywhere it can be done anywhere
under any means there is no one rule for
this something there's pros and cons to
everything so no one right way but again
if you have great leaders of a big
company they're going to see your
passion if they're great and they're
going to actually try to nurture it and
help grow because they need to grow and
they need great great talent Gaby
asked a question which is very related
and you might already answered it he
says do you think it's possible to find
fulfilment but working for a company or
do you think founding your own company
being CEO brings more fulfillment
fulfillment is in the eye of the
beholder you have to look for what
you're trying to learn you need to set
your own goals whether it's as a
start-up as an independent or inside a
big company either my first question I
ask out you can do yeah you have you and
you can do either the big thing that I
asked when I interview people is I say
what do you want to learn when you come
here what do you want to learn not what
can you do for me what do you want to
learn because if you are always trying
to learn then I know you're trying to
improve yourself and therefore you're
going to help the company improve as
well when you that's a great lead away
to a question Maya for euphonium okay
part of it from the script here but then
you interview people how do you pick
them you just mentioned this one
question like how do you assess for the
people really willing to learn it was
trying to please you well the other the
other thing I asked is about their
background so I go through their resume
or in even if they don't have experience
you know maybe some people don't have
experience I had a very little
experience when I came here was how did
you pick your major how did you discover
you wanting to do what you really want
to do how did you
no when you wanted to become an engineer
or a you know a doctor or whatever I
always want to see that insight do they
understand what their gut is telling
them can they articulate that and then
you can understand if they're really
about pleasing you or trying to
challenge themselves and get better and
so that's a you have to really listen
close one to people who then go to their
gut W want to be open to learning and
open to failure absolutely open to
failure
they are people you know we don't learn
to walk when we we learn to walk we
don't walk when we come out of the womb
we have to learn everything and there's
failure along the way and you have to
understand those moments of adversity
and those moments of triumph and how
those people dealt with it and that's
the way I can assess I think I can
assess good talent because we're
adaptable creatures we can learn all
kinds of things if we want to learn it's
such was that's so true a question from
in us do you feel you needed the Apple
work experience that you of course had
to start your own company do you think
if you start up your own company years
earlier which I guess you did in the egg
delivery business and egg delivery or
education company could if done equally
well if you were to take all this this
phase of you we had this amazing impact
at Apple and invented these wonderful
things but it didn't have it would this
have come out the same way I don't think
it'd be the same but I think it might
have it would have existed absolutely
you know a people look inside of app but
it's an incredible company with
incredible talent and processes in that
way but there's lots of the incredible
companies out there and again you know I
learned a lot of things at General magic
that was an Apple I learned it at
General magic or I learned it at Philips
Electronics every single place you go
there's always something you can learn
you just have to be tuned into it and so
yeah I learned a lot of great things at
Apple but at the end of the day it
boiled down to tenacity the people you
know and the things you knew through
your experiences you can't build a new
company without not understanding
yourself but also knowing a network of
people who can help you build it because
most companies are not just one person
it's a group of Pho and you need to have
a network of people to help you and
empower them to help you Tony you're a
world-class does
you want awards for your work and design
and you led teams and when I asked you
about nest you often tell me that you
see yourself as a chief designer this is
the CEO and you are obviously here's a
question from Duncan when you design a
product a Tony how do you decide whether
to include a feature or cut a feature I
have to smile because we are perennial
question every CEO however the to
include a feature over the ducati
feature right are there rules that you
follow yes there are absolutely rules I
know they are but tell us I won't tell
you the rice so we have to talk wheat
first you have to segment out are you a
business-to-business product or service
or you a business to consumer product
it's very different things so if you're
trying to sell to another corporation
usually that corporation will tell you
what they want and what they don't want
so it's pretty easy so you're like I
need to cut this feature I need to
include this feature because I'm going
to make a sale I'm going to get a
customer from it so it's up it not that
it's easy by any means I'm not trying to
say it but you luckily you have somebody
who's right there and you can assess
what you really should do now on the
business-to-consumer side like an apple
or a Google or something like that you
say I have you know the team has to
pre-ordained and figure out what those
customers or want you're not going to
talk to all of them so you have to
figure out how you're going to
communicate to that consumer what
they're going to get and you only have
three or four top things that you can
communicate many engineers sit there and
they say they need a litany they need 30
40 different features to be able to sell
something
the problem is consumers only have a
very limited amount of time this company
general magic that I started with we
spent four years building something
because we thought we needed every
single feature general magic lost a
billion dollars on was one of the
biggest failures in Silicon Valley
because we put too many features in and
it took four hours to explain what the
product was you have to remember people
have very limited of time you only have
three or four things amazing things you
can tell people it locks me vd1 know
what happens in these television
companies when the designers discuss the
design of remote controls right right
I've never seen a remote control where
over the life
I used every single button you know what
I mean oh look at a car cars also have
redundant buttons there's people over
design and what I find is in InDesign is
that engineers try especially in the
early days of their career and I did
this even happened to general magic and
me we would sit there and we would try
to impress the person next to us we
would try to say I'm gonna make
something so cool that they're impressed
and then they go wow that's really cool
and they want to do it again and again
but what you're doing is you're
impressing and making features for
somebody who really understands and they
you know and it gets really geeky what
your job is that a great engineer and
designer is to not make things for the
engineer next to you but it's to make it
for the common person who doesn't
understand the technology that the way
you do to make it community so you can
communicate this is what it does and
what you also do is you make sure that
that um how can I put this that the
product itself is empowering that person
you're giving that person who buying
that product a superpower you've made it
so simple for them you've taken this
great robust technology and made it so
simple for them they use it and they
feel like they have a new superpower
they've never had Google was a perfect
example right so our job as engineers
and as designers is to give superpowers
to our consumers make the technology so
simple but so powerful that this person
feels enabled that they've never seen
impact and I have to ask this question
no biggest totally not the world-class
designer about Tonio's the world-class
CEO before you launch say before you
launch and nest thermostats the only
person I can impress as an engineer is
the person next to me how do you how do
you get that DNA that you just talked
about into your staff and your team well
I think the first and foremost thing is
you have to mentor your staff to say you
need to come in with your hat a beginner
hat on everyday what is you know we look
at all the design
we look at all the details every day and
we get you know nuanced of how we're
going to how we're going to make a
decision we have to come back with step
take a step back the I am a new user
I've never seen this before
explain to me the very first step
explained me the second step explained
to me the third slide and I am a junior
engineer and surrounded by 30 people I
wish to impress and it's so easy to say
we need this I came with this great new
feature this excellent new button we can
put on right how do you get a team to
say no well so there are data-driven
decisions and there are other
data-driven decisions and there's
opinion based decisions yeah okay you
must have a a one or a small team of
people who are in charge of the opinion
based decisions and they're the ones who
are going to carry the vision to make
sure it's going to stay intact all the
way to market so data-driven decisions
are easy because everyone can see what
the right thing to do is opinion you
need a small one or a couple people who
are going to be the guiding light and
that's where you either see a visionary
CEO what that is or a small product
design team and then they help to work
with everybody to educate why it is what
we're building what it is for the
consumer and they're the ones who can
help shape and mold it nice so if you're
getting online question on this iPad and
this is a question from a student named
Dell hydel what is the secret to
survival after a failure no of course
you never fail you wouldn't know this
but my god oh man like I could write be
$24 I would spot everybody else and
that's it you know a failure you know
and anytime there's a failure you have
to look into it you know it like general
magically I've said you know there's
always success in failure
you just have to know where to look for
it and that means that's a learning
moment so you say Evie Vega is success
in learning if you know how to learn
exactly you just have to look for it
because then you use that again and you
make sure you don't make that mistake
again or don't allow that mistake to
have it so your goal is to then just
because it didn't work out the way you
wanted to take that knowledge take those
learnings and
apply it to a new you know a new
direction and therefore you're going to
get better no one's you know you've had
I've had failure and it takes years of
building up that kind of thick skin
around you of really understanding what
it is right you know like I said you had
to fall down many times learning to walk
and run you're gonna do the same thing
in life I'm just all right you're gonna
bruise yourself you're gonna break your
bones what have you but that's what it
means to be resilient you just get up
and you keep going and you can and I
can't tell you there's been times when I
just sat there those like oh the world's
gonna be over and then you know what you
just look at it and you think about it
and you have to project yourself not
today but to project yourself into the
future what could I do in the future if
you keep looking ahead that's you know
don't get target fixation don't look
here you're gonna hit the tree what
you're saying is forward your dopamine
in your brain doesn't come to us from
the superficial success but from the
learning success I'm the learning
success so if you fail you're really
happy because you never make the same
mistake again exactly and look forward
keep looking forward in the past
everybody fails you're not the only one
everybody does just get over it keep
going it's such a great attitude here's
a technical question from Sarah which is
offline what made you change from
creating iPods which you're very famous
for to creating thermostats and she's
also very famous for it looks like a
dissidence above the surface these
products seem completely different well
they are well they're on the surface
level and the markets everything are
completely different the difference is
and I said earlier is it first started
with frustration
so the iPod was born out of for me the
frustration I had as a DJ I had to carry
all these CDs around I was mad I was
frustrated I couldn't get all the music
I wanted it was heavy was cumbersome I
had to go find things and I couldn't be
as good a DJ as I wanted so I that was
the frustration my curiosity and then
solution the thermostat I was sick and
tired of paying so much money for a for
energy to heat my home or cool my home
and yet it wasn't very comfortable and
every time I left it you know it didn't
turn off and I was just pissed I was mad
so you know 50% of the money we spent on
energy every year
was due to this thermostat yeah and it
was ugly so I was frustrated then
curious then solution was interested
because the thermostat I think broke
many of the rules in Silicon Valley if
you'd ask me guess you didn't ask me
because I knew you were an adviser yeah
I would have said look there's things to
turn upon quickly like your meal your
your your phone your pen and then things
that turn around very very slowly
including your education your car or car
your home your home and as a result if
the turnover cycle is slow how can you
get a fast innovation cycle going in the
slow turnaround market but you defy the
odds completely as say I was actually
done you did thank thank you but you
know it was because of the fact that
people every month would get a bill our
energy bill and they would just be
frustrating they just had to you know
pay it and they would just they didn't
know what they were doing it was just
like I gotta pay this and he just
couldn't take it so each month when they
get that bill that's the frustration we
just had to make sure we had a great
product that could deliver on the
marketing message and make sure they
heard the message whether they were in a
store or online or what have you so we
just had to tap in and I call this the
virus of doubt what's the pain point and
make sure you're a pain killer not a
vitamin so the pain was the energy bill
and then we said we had a we had the the
antidote for that and the pain came
every month that's true but he also made
look beautiful we have to make it look
beautiful so for me I bought maybe 30 of
those I admit and then I get a special
to you from you have a paid full retail
price I give half away as gifts to
people thank you very much thank you one
of the most beautiful gifts to give on a
sweetness and would joy about the
thermostat in particular it has a shot a
piece of jewelry on your walls it's so
nice to see it and smile at you thank
you and make it so easy to use I think
that I mean this is a brilliance of of
your engineering thank you solve a big
energy problem for the nation everybody
had one you could probably reduce about
how much person so right now what is
energy
so right now in a home v at least 15
percent we could save in homes of energy
and we've saved over seven billion
kilowatt hours and people are not
still customer huge and is uses more
than many politicians cleaner to save so
speeches they waste more here's an
online question from James who asked
about Internet of Things and he wants to
be get your assessment of the valuable
availability as I guess of a business he
- if it's better to be in IT IOT devices
or more the data business right now like
if you were to start something want to
be the data business or the device
business I think that you know each it's
a general question either one can work
either one can work it's what you're
passionate about again
people always start to go from you know
they going with the biggest market and
then they try to form their business
around this biggest market and they go
find the problems and then they solve
them but they're not really passionate
about solving them they're solving them
for money yeah the difference is is when
you solve them for your frustration you
go after it and then if you work really
hard and you put all the passion and
love into that product whether it's a
software heart or a product or a data
product whatever it is people will feel
that passion when they use it
yeah and that's the way the money will
come stop looking at the money and going
to find the solution start with the
problem go intelligent to deliver that
solution that's meaningful and and
that's true and then the customers will
come I love how you say this because I
think from the outside Silicon Valley is
often perceived as a as a money-making
machine like you see a sale of whatsapp
to to Facebook for 18 billion dollars
and everybody scratches their head 19
billion dollar zero right plus retention
bonuses and says these guys could beauty
rich and I want to get rich but you're
saying something else you're saying
something completely different
absolutely you know when I started the
when I started thinking about nest I
told my wife Danny and she goes you're
absolutely crazy a thermostat how is
that gonna be like an iPod you're not
gonna make a lot of money I'm like I'm
telling you I'm and then I explained in
five minutes you go that's a great idea
would impact it Vitamix only wanted a
win-win-win and then if we won on energy
for any environment and we made people
happy and more comfortable we're gonna
win as a company yeah so if you make
other people the winners they're gonna
reward you and
that was all it was it about it wasn't
about you know I could have gone and
done different iPod or a different thing
because I was chasing the money it was
chasing the passion the you know the
thing that I really wanted to fix that I
thought was meaningful and then the
world lida omits is asking a question
after when having the idea in my mind
when he has an idea what is the best
practice to to apply the idea and and
implement it and execute idea well like
how do you go about checking how
valuable this do you just well I got a
company right away do you know as your
parent well we did well don't ask your
parents your parents are always gonna
validate you that's a great idea do
never ask your parents it's a good idea
or not okay great Sharon's ask your
spouse I'm great parents but don't ask
him because they're always gonna say
that's wonderful honey it's great they
love you unconditionally whether it's a
good idea or a bad idea they're gonna
say it's great you're seeing a spouse as
the opposite spouse is the opposite
should be they should be truthful that's
what you want is a great partner so um
no it starts with an idea and in nest it
took almost a whole year before we
started the company so what did you do
in this year form like I want to do a
thermostat that's like reducing energy
consumption you saw this amazing ways of
the air conditioner running all David
people aren't at home to finally
incorporating and raising money right so
I think the the way that it's first
started was how might I think I could
solve this problem technically so is do
I have enough of the pieces do I know
enough of the things and I said yeah I
know that because I had enough
experience of that so here first had to
research enough about what you think
would be built it then after that you
started researching the market like how
many are sold how do you do that II we
have this great tool called Google and
we could sit there and Google all over
that look in thermostats at the time I
think thermistors lasts an average of
about 20 years ten years I don't know
Harlow yes twelve years you must have
come back and say now I'm not a market
because no one ever buys in with Homa
still and unless they sell their home in
the answer is that you're no one extra
Linda go for the cheapest possible
because they don't care about the next
owners January sentence so you have to
remember when your
RUP ting and industry and if you have
something dramatically different if you
have disruptive technology then you can
change a stagnated market yes like let's
take the iPod
there were mp3 players at the time there
were CD Walkmans and all those different
things but in the mp3 player market if
you looked at the size of the mp3 player
market and you saw that it was a tiny
little product for geeks but if you
looked at all the problems with that
product but if you also looked at the
promise of the product and said they
didn't meet you said wait a second this
could be a lot better so don't point to
the market size point to the impact it
could have if you do it right so how do
you do market research and something
that doesn't have a market yet that is a
great question
so the way that I've seen it is that you
eat you have to start with the idea what
are you changing and you have to take
bold steps in terms of making something
and trying it now you have to test lots
of testing so you would make something
and then you would go to a you know some
of the industry leaders or some of the
people you really trust who are
knowledgeable about a given area and
you'd say what do you think
what do you think and then you start to
to set your risk level based on how big
the market is or how big them how big
you think the market might become so did
you go out to people and say here's my
drawing with the nest thermostats would
you buy it uh yeah I did but to people I
trusted people who I really valued their
opinion like you yeah I looked at it and
was blown away I mean I remember the day
when we were introduced and said I have
this amazing product and I was safe make
my contribution to climate change my
climate change and I couldn't guess what
it was because you said it's in every
home it's in and you can do it yes I can
and then you show me what it is and was
really amazed and that was machine
learning before people who knew what
machine learning well it's like what's
happening today you were the first well
one who helped you help but you know
absolutely that was a so you have to
look at the disruptive technology and
how it could take an existing industry
or that the moves there's not too many
things that come up that does and are
not going to disrupt an industry that
you're not going to take customers from
this place over here typically most
things that you build are going to take
customers from someplace and displace
them to yours so you can kind of figure
out what the market size might become
over time interesting I mean since to
talk about it can you give us kind of
asset question to give us a bit of a
vision of Internet of Things
say 20 years from now 20 thing well let
me let me tell you know Internet of
Things is a very big broad vision let's
just talk about the home right let's
talk about good so in the home you know
when when I was growing up what you do
when you went into the home you when you
went into back home you would you know
or when you left home when you left home
knocked the door or you unlock the door
you turn on live do you you do all these
different things and what you do you
would put on you would put on your
jacket you would put on your shoes and
you'd walk out the door well today you
still turn off the lights and do all
those other things but you pick up your
mobile phone put on your jacket
put on your shoes and you walk out the
door right of the same thing same thing
except their mobile phones with you and
now what we've been saying is the mobile
phone is the way you're going to control
everything when you're outside the home
but it's also the mobile phones with you
when you're inside the home at all times
right it's this thing that's always with
you well I hope that in the home we're
going to get rid of mobile phones in the
home why because what do mobile phones
do they do this I'm using it and I'm
it's distancing between the loved ones
you got your iPad or your whim I don't
want focus right now right at anybody
I'm not to get a mobile phone I'm
putting this between you and your loved
ones yeah my hope is that over the next
10 to 20 years just like when you come
home and you take off your shoes and you
take off your jacket you take your
mobile phone and you throw it in the
corner and and that's the whole head has
its there all those great resources
computing is there but it's an voice
recognition voice recognition but you
know we're you're gonna it's gonna
recognize your gate who's home it's
gonna recognize the voice of who's there
it's going to recognize what room you're
in
and it's the computing is going to be
ambient around you so even your PC
disappears and if you even your DVC
disappear look some
you have it and the only time you're
going to have a display is when you're
going to do group viewing so you want to
get around and watch a movie or do what
have it do what have you as a family our
goal is to get rid of the technology
barriers between you and your loved ones
you know what you're describing to me is
as volution areas going from a
typewriter through a computer
I'm sure if you said in the room of
people who typewriters in telling the
system your computer it's going to be
connected you can browse through your
websites that would sound completely
crazy yeah exactly
and I think in the home you still in
this age really we operate our home
exactly like our typewriters absolutely
and in there and we're getting to the
point where we're going to be able to
stop making timers making them desktop
computers hopefully soon it's going to
become a mobile phone in the home but
it's gonna be ambient it's gonna be all
around you and that mobile phone is
going to be ditched only when you're on
the road so you would save you only one
to three percent into the Internet of
Things or the more we are at the very
earliest earliest days this is this is
like the app were rated out at the Apple
two days of the internet of things at
home it's true you just left ever'one
things to necess true
another thing LG by initial devices
that's something great for our students
because you put this together with the
question what makes you uncomfortable
there's so many things I hate about my
home little tough to fix so many great
startup companies to be built such a
great for you to be in I want to take
another online question from yours if by
chance do you have a recipe to becoming
addicted to learning addicted to
learning Wow
I you know I think it's innate I think
it's innate I think it's always asking
questions like you don't have to take a
course to learn you learn from each
other right
it's always about asking you know lots
of people like to tell themselves will
talk about themselves with everyone I I
learned back in when I was in high
school listen more listen more how can
you do this so when I grew up in Germany
my professors would never ever ask a
question because it's a professor I'm
supposed to your Oracle you know
everything so our role models did the
opposite so how did you manage to escape
that you know I went to twelve different
schools in 15 years
I went to 12 different school didn't
kick you out today
my father was on the lam no no no but no
seriously so every time I was always
learning because I was always in a new
environment I never was a master of in
my environment because it was always
changing you should never think you're a
master of in your environment this is
about staying beginners to know what
kind of product you're gonna make you
always have to just question and if you
so there's two things so one is always
question and if you're always
questioning that means you're curious
and that means you're going to have the
potential to learn if you listen okay
and listen to others that are round to
gain knowledge from them and the other
one is just keep trying keep listening
keep learning and apply that knowledge
and keep applying that knowledge and as
you dig deeper you're going to find
there's more things to learn and more
things to learn stay curious what a
great challenge to all our students
let's see there's another question from
Roger what do you see as key steps or
habits to converting ideas into reality
I guess squishy already talked about a
little bit persistence that's so after
the learning and the curiosity it's just
keep try and keep trying you know nest
nest the thermostat wasn't the first
idea I had no bird nest
it was the third idea I had for nest so
and we're getting around to all those
other ideas they were that was the most
important I'm not going to talk about
but there was the most important idea
but it was always just that like there
was not enough in my gut saying that
when you say keep persistence I can't
help but pointing out that you tell
people students keep learning and be
persistent and those could be
contradictory like if I think I have the
right solution and just want to get it
doing it's really easy to fall into this
this local minimum where I just blindly
do the same thing over and over and
hammer the same nail that in the holiday
sanity but Bible people do this like
what are you persistent about so there
are times when you're learning and then
you're persistent to getting to an
answer then you go back to learning so
it's a phased approach so too resistant
to go to an answer right so you have an
Apothic
you test the hypothesis you make a new
hypothesis then you keep going so it's a
process so you have to know when to step
on the gas or when you
put on the brakes to learn then you step
on the gas to do but it's ordered your
problem potent is a vision for this
process like a distant goal that you
wouldn't complex you always have to have
a Northstar you always have to know
where you're going now you're not going
to get there straight but you have to
end your North Star will change over
time as you learn and adapt but you
should always know what you're trying to
go for and it shouldn't be for money you
should be going for what you what thing
you're trying to solve for right and
maybe it's the wrong thing but you'll
learn over time here's a question as
close to my heart as I'm turning 49
today and the question is from AJ what
is your advice for someone over 50 years
old to transition into new technologies
oh I have a lot of learners of all
trades of life at Udacity and they come
to us at all ages and that's wonderful
it's great it's just you know in fact I
would argue today's society lifelong
learning is not a big big thing that we
propagate but we see many students
exactly taking one career and then after
20 years in Vancouver go to new career
but when being asked is it chance for
somebody age 50 what what do you advise
absolutely you know I said earlier you
know if you're going to a great company
who understands how to interview people
and and under and and and understand
their innate potential if you've had
success and you've shown success and
learning along the ways of failure out
of or success out of failure they're
going to see that and they're going to
see your passion because it's no
different than running to when you were
20 years old when you when you didn't
know anything right so if you have a
career and you just say I'm switching
careers I'm changing it but you're
taking this wealth of knowledge into a
new domain a lot of the thing with
employers is that they always want
multidisciplinary people yeah they want
people from all kinds of different
backgrounds to bring it there so if they
see oh my god you have this wealth of
knowledge from this other thing that's
going to help me with my my whatever I'm
creating and you wanted to learn this -
they're going I want to learn from you
your your experience and you're going to
learn from me this new experience you
want to learn if it's a if it's a if
it's a two-way street of learners both
parties or both parties are succeed
together and that's what Kate's a great
bond and creates a great product or
great service totally almost out of time
and I find your answers incredibly
insightful I have to admit I learned so
much just from talking to you I want to
ask you one last question tell us
something that no one really knows about
something that you experienced in your
life that you would even look back and
say my god the Charlie Rose question huh
let's see hmm just tell you a story or
something about some interesting story
some interesting stuff
you're being viewed as the superhero the
person who turns everything into gold to
was not just great a great CEO one of
the best almost times but also a great
designer a great Hardware person a great
software person I mean I like just human
I'm just human I'm just human know that
I think the biggest thing it's all about
the people it's all about the people you
you work with they become your friends
those friends become people that you you
trust again this whole curiosity and
learning and in doing you could you're a
magnet for these different types of
people right and they will be there to
support you when you fail and they'll
help you learn and then when they're
trying to do something you're going to
be there for them the biggest thing is
about all of us working together to
support each other because that's we
really heard about it so for me my my
love is that general magic right here
downstairs when it was here I was the
lowest guy on the totem pole I came to
Silicon Valley I didn't know no one
these people helped me become who I was
today Andy Hertzfeld Joanne aha is Susan
care Susan care was pregnant at the time
when I was 22 when I came to general
magic she had a baby her baby his name
was Harry guess what Harry is now at
nest and he was one of the biggest best
performers you could ever imagine and
he's in his 20s passionate a learner and
that's the generational effect first it
started with his mother she transferred
that to me now I'm helping her son and
that's what Silicon Valley's about and
that's what life's about
lifelong learning and
you not just learning but also mentoring
and I'm learning more from Harry than
he's probably learning from me and
that's what that's the magic of what how
I get to be successful it's through
others and I help them make success as
well Tony's been incredibly privileged
and wonderful learning experience for me
to have your nose very very first
inaugural Udacity talks we will have our
nest the next guest will be Astro teller
who is the captain of moon shots at
Google X and also a good friend of mine
but I and it's going to be in June first
so please sign up today but thank you so
much for coming it's been a privilege
Sebastian you're a good friend and I
can't thank you enough for today I'm
learning as well so thank you thank you
congratulations with all Udacity success
I'm going to do all your successes